page naturisme toujours avec une
guéguerre qui oppose à port leucate
nudistes et textiles comme on dit un
promoteur parisien en effet soldées cet
hiver des appartements près de cette
plage sans insister trop sur le fait
qu'ils étaient édifiés en pleine zone
naturiste un petit reportage au poil
signé son rythme et olivier combe
oui la charte de moi qui ai pris ma b et
puis ils veulent pas se mettre et savent
quelque chose que nous supportons un
mémento loup avait tout comme moi qui
suis là en location
on nous précise pas que tous mettent à
nu sur la plage
il était une fois un paradis entre mr
immeuble depuis 18 ans d adam et eve
viennent y passer leurs vacances nuque h
et heureux jusqu'à cet été ou des
textiles ont investi la plage la chasse
aux maillots étaient ouverts il traite
de voyeur nous bce les voyeurs parce que
ils sont habillés dans l'axé de moi ici
sur cette plage des gens en maillot de
bain dans quelques années nous sommes
obligés de remettre le maillot de bain
la pomme de discorde
elle est le fait d'un promoteurs
indélicats qui depuis paris vendait ses
maisonnettes au rabais dans cette zone
classée nudistes en se gardant bien de
préciser que le nu était obligatoire
même si le contrat de vente mentionne le
naturisme beaucoup s'y sont laissés
prendre
nous quand on a acheté nous a jamais dit
que c'était nudistes nous a dit qu'il y
avait des gens nous disent qu'ils
habitaient derrière chez nous donc qui
passeraient devant chez nous c'est tout
on a du bon ce n'est aucun problème
maintenant on nous interdit presque la
plage bon alors c'est totalement
différent de ce qu'on nous avait dit
c'est tout donc là dessus il me sens
trompé en fin de compte les uns refusent
le sectarisme des inconditionnels du nu
les autres tentent de préserver cet art
de vivre qu'elle naturisme il ya vingt
mille nature et sur une plage il ya
trois personnes habillées parce que
l'allemand de la formation
j'ai recherché l'intrus représentant une
entité très important de l'économie qui
a pas de problème sur la plage restera
tout aventurisme pour que leur vie ne
devienne pas un enfer certains habitants
de l'éden ont préféré se convertir
d'autres trouvent un compromis mon fils
est il enlève le haut mais bon c'est
déjà chaud ni déjà bien quelques
irréductibles ne baisserons pas la
culotte
ce qui n'empêchera nullement les deux
camps de profiter de la vie après tout
ils sont en vacances